i wish they would eat you you [ __ ]
monster
do you know who else would say that
carol [ __ ] baskin hi i'm thomas
chipperfield i'm a lion trainer and i'm
going to be reacting to some of your
comments on my videos
[Music]
all right let's go the world still has
lion tamers in 2019
yes we do and it's 20 20.
i thought animals in circuses were
banned the answer to that is
in the uk wild animals in travelling
circuses
is banned you can work with wild animals
in any other setting
and you can still work with domestic
animals in a circus
i wonder if anyone has ever been injured
by his animals
looks dangerous i've never been
injured by the big cats where it's
required any attention i've had
things like i've been head-butted by the
lions i've had the lions fall on me
i've even had one slap me once but i've
never had
anything that would require any
treatment
of any serious kind if the animals
weren't happy this man would be dead by
now
get over it that's the right answer
there
these animals are very powerful very
strong and
they are smart enough to know that
i don't stand a chance i wish they would
eat you you [ __ ] monster
do you know who else would say that
carol [ __ ] baskin
i'm quite used to the death threats at
this point i have to say
i've been threatened people threatened
to shoot me
people have threatened to burn me in a
stack of tires
people have threatened to kidnap me and
torture me
and people are threatened to kidnap my
mother and just lots of lovely stuff
really i do have to with
reasonable regularity keep my
local police force informed of these
sort of things so it's it's never nice
because to a degree you have to take
this sort of
thing seriously but for the most part
it's
it's nearly always just been words and
not action where does he actually get
these animals from
black market no
no we've bred a lot of our animals
ourselves and then others we've sourced
from
other circuses and then from other
private collectors
and the like we don't actually source
animals from the black market and the
truth is i wouldn't even know where to
begin to look for the black market
circuses
known to be vile to their animals also
now
illegal in the uk drugged declawed and
teeth removed
false no i don't
drug my animals i don't declaw them
and their teeth aren't removed how would
they eat if they don't have any teeth
i couldn't pass an inspection without
those
sort of things being checked upon
drugged animals show
very very specific behaviors that are
abnormal
so that wouldn't pass any scrutiny from
a vet
declawing is also not something that's
even
legal in the uk unless it's for very
necessary
animal welfare reasons and all of my
animals have their claws anyway
so that's that's just
not true this guy looks like a knockoff
of
ryan reynolds
oh god well i'll take that as a
compliment
ryan reynolds is a good looking guy this
is awful
how can he say he's not cruel when he
has a rod which he will use
to hit the lions if they don't do as
instructed
i use the bamboo cane for what's called
target training it's a practice that's
used
in zoos for various animals although not
many zoos work in a free contact
capacity with big cats
but it is a practice that's been used
widely throughout circus history
the idea is you actually teach the
animals because
felids are very inquisitive and playful
in the same way that people
tease their cats with a toy on the end
of a string or something like that
you teach the animals to come forward to
chase the canes functionally
and from there you just build up to
rewarding that behavior
to the point where they associate
following the cane
with a reward it's not actually to push
them
away as such or to hit them with circus
tricks can be taught without causing
pain
whether or not it's natural is
it's not really relevant because there's
a lot of things that people do for
animals that are unnatural
it's unnatural to give them medication
to deal with
illnesses it's unnatural to
treat injuries training any animal in
itself
is unnatural but it doesn't equate to
wrong seems like an intelligent guy
who's fully focused and knows exactly
what he's doing seems
to be mutual respect by all parties
involved he treats them well
and cares for the conservation of these
animals and also the welfare of the
animals
until they eat him so you were doing
really
really well i was starting to well up
and everything
and then you just lost me mate you
really did
there's no danger of me being eaten by
my animals as long as i do my job
properly
so for my sake you should hope i do that
properly
type in chipperfield circus cruelty
well you know
type in drinking your own urine cures
cancer
you'll find what you're looking for
but no more more seriously yeah i think
i think this comment is referring to
mary chipperfield who
is a cousin of mine somewhere down the
line
she's actually no longer with us and she
got a lot of criticism and face charges
of animal cruelty
when i was 10 and i was also in a
different country
so i can't really comment directly on
anything that i saw because i didn't see
anything
it is frustrating to have what someone
else allegedly did thrown at me because
that's just not a reasonable way of
thinking
like at the end of the day i prefer to
be judged by my own
actions and on my own merits at the end
of the day
i can't claim the credit for opening
longleaf safari park which my great
uncle did and i certainly can't claim
the credit
for harboring jews during the holocaust
which the altoff circus family
in germany did so why should i be
burdened
with the guilt of anyone's
sins from in the circus community at
loud bible
who gives a flying [ __ ] anyway
well this is my work i do i'm really
sorry but i care deeply about this
everything i thought about schizophrenia
was
i guess like from the media and that was
all people with schizophrenia were
dangerous and violent and
i just i couldn't i really couldn't take
it in for a long time this diagnosis it
took me years to
deal with it to be honest